as kids gear up for a new school year
there are several new schools opening
along with several that have just moved
into new facilities
madison kimbrough stopped by two
elementary schools that held their
ribbon cuttings today inside of their
new buildings
she joins us live in front of george e
harris elementary at sand hill and twain
madison pretty exciting for students
right
yes i got a tour and take a look for
yourself it's quite pretty out here and
the inside is quite stunning too
the parents and kids i spoke with were
very pleased with how everything looked
i feel pretty happy the classroom looked
awesome
it had a lot of space students parents
and staff excited for what this new year
will bring
with brand new replacement schools
friday a sneak peek inside george e
harris and farron elementary schools
it's exciting for the kids to be in a
new building
so that they can gain a quality
education in addition mabel hogard
elementary
myrtle tate elementary and sandy valley
high all have new campuses too
superintendent dr jesus jarrah sharing
his excitement about these new
facilities
our work has continued and has
intensified during covenant we're going
to deliver
world class education in a 21st century
classroom
mamashima carter says having her kids
back in the classroom is a much needed
step in the right direction
they were doing the distance learning
for so long
and part of me didn't think didn't know
how they were going to really come out
of it
but to see that everybody got feet on
the ground running getting back in
school 100 percent now
it means a lot to me two brand new
schools open doors on monday
berry and june gunderson middle school
in the southwest valley
as well as hannah marie brown elementary
in henderson
and as a reminder school does begin on
monday so give yourself plenty of time
out on the road
police will be out in full force making
sure that you're not speeding in any of
these school zones so be careful
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now